- [Instructor] Now that
we know a little bit about
how to construct a unit normal vector
at any point in a curve,
that's what we did in the last video,
I want to start exploring
an interesting expression.
So the expression is the line
integral around a closed loop,
and we're gonna go in the positive,
counterclockwise orientation,
of a vector field F,
dotted with the unit normal vector
at any point on that curve ds,
I'll write ds in magenta, ds.
So first let's conceptualize
what this is even saying,
and then let's manipulate it a little bit
to see if we can come up with
and interesting conclusion.
We actually will manipulate it.
we'll use Green's theorem,
and we're gonna actually come up
with a two-dimensional version
of the divergence theorem,
which all sounds very complicated,
but hopefully we can get a
little bit of an intuition for it
as to why it actually a
little bit of common sense.
So first, lets just think about this.
So let me draw a coordinate plane here.
So let me do it in white.
So this right over
here, that's our y-axis.
That over there is our x-axis.
Let me draw ourselves my curve.
So my curve might look something like...
I'll do it in the blue color.
So my curve might look
something like this, my contour,
and its going in the positive,
counterclockwise direction just like that.
And now we have our vector field,
and, just a reminder, we've
seen this multiple times.
My vector field will associate a vector
with any point on the x-y plane,
and it can be defined as
some function of x and y,
actually, I'll call that P,
some function of x and y
times the i unit vector.
So it says what the i component
of the vector field is
for any x and y point,
and then what the j component,
or what we multiply the j component by
or the vertical component
by for any x and y point.
So some function of x and y times i
plus some other scalar
function of x and y times j.
And so, if you give me any point,
there'll be an associated vector with it.
Any point, there's an associated vector,
depending on how we define this function.
But this expression right over here,
we're taking a line integral.
We care specifically about
the points along this curve,
along this contour right over here.
And so let's think about what
this piece right over here
is actually telling us before we sum up
all of these infinitesimally small pieces.
So if we just take F dot n,
so let's just think about
a point on this curve.
A point on this curve, maybe
this point right over here.
So associated with that
point, there is a vector.
That's what the vector field does.
F might look something
like that right over there.
So that might be F at that point,
and then we're gonna dot it
with the unit normal vector at that point.
So the unit normal vector
might look something like that.
That would be n hat at that point.
This is the vector field at that point.
When you take the dot product,
you get a scaler quantity.
You essentially just get a
number and you might remember it
and there's several
videos where we go into
detail about this but
that tells you how much
those two vectors go together.
It's essentially, if they're
completely orthogonal
to each other you're gonna
get zero and if they go
completely in the same
direction it's essentially
just gonna multiply their
magnitudes times each other.
And since you have a
unit normal vector here,
what this is essentially going
to give you is the magnitude
of the vector field F that
goes in the normal direction.
So, think of it this way.
So let's think about the component of this
that goes in the normal direction.
It might look something
like that, this would be
the component that goes
the tangential direction.
So, this expression right
over here is going to give us
the magnitude of this vector.
Let me write this down,
this right over here is the
magnitude of the component
of F, in the normal direction
or in the same direction
as that unit normal vector.
Normal direction.
And then were gonna multiply
that times a very infinitely
small length of our contour,
of our curve right around that point.
So were gonna multiply that thing,
times this right over here.
And so you might say, "Well,
you know, okay, I kind of
"get what that is saying but
"how could this ever
be physically relevant,
"or what could be the intuition for what
"this expression is even measuring?"
And to think about
that, I always visualize
this is in two dimensions.
You will later do things like this
in three dimensions, so imagine this is
a two dimensional universe
and we're studying gases.
And so you have all these gas
particles in a two dimensional
universe so they only can have
kind of an x and y coordinate
and this vector field is essentially
telling you the velocity
at any point there.
So this is the velocity of
the particles at this point,
this is the velocity of
particles at that point,
that is the velocity of
particles at that point.
And so, when you take F right
on this curve, that's the
velocity of the particles at that point
they're going in that direction.
When you dot it with N it tells you,
essentially, the speed going straight out
right at that point, and then when
you multiply that times ds,
you're essentially saying,
at any given moment, how
fast, or at that point
right over there on the curve,
how fast are the particles
exiting the curve?
And so if you were to sum up all of them
which is essentially what this
integral is doing with the
slight integral, it's essentially saying,
how fast are the particles
exiting this contour?
Are they even entering
the contour if you get
a negative number?
But since were taking the
unit normal vector that
is outward-pointing, it's saying,
"How fast are they exiting this thing?"
If you've got a negative
number, that means
there might be some net entrance.
So, this whole expression
is if you take that analogy,
it doesn't have to have that
physical representation,
how fast are particles, are
two dimensional gas particles
exiting the contour?
In the future, you can do three dimensions
where you have a surface and you can say,
"How fast are things
exiting this surface?"
And so let's start, now
that we hopefully have
a decent conceptual understanding of what
this could represent let's play
around with it a little bit,
especially because we know
how to define a normal vector.
So, let's rewrite it using what we know
about how to construct a normal vector.
So, if we rewrite it our
integral becomes this.
We have our vector field F,
dotted with the normal vector.
The normal vector we can write this way.
A normal vector we saw was
dy times y minus dx times j.
And then we had to divide
it by its magnitude.
In order to make it a unit normal vector,
the magnitude was this right over here,
dx squared by dy squared,
which is the same thing
as ds which is the same thing
as that little mini arc length
that infinitely small
length of our contour.
So, we're going to divide it by ds.
We're going to divide it by ds.
And then we're going to
multiply it times ds.
We're going to multiply it by ds.
And ds is just a scanner quality,
and so we can actually even multiply
this thing times ds before
taking the dot product
or vice versa.
But these two things
are going to cancel out.
And so we're essentially
left with F dot this thing
right over here.
But we have F defined
right over here so let's
take the dot products.
I'll just write the line
integral symbol again.
We're going in the
counterclockwise direction.
And when we evaluate and now let's in--
let me pick a color that I have not used.
I may have used many colors
so I'll do yellow again.
So now, let's evaluate
F dot this business.
So, dot product fairly straightforward.
You take the product of the x-components,
or essentially the magnitude
of the x-components.
So, it's going to be P of
Y, P of xy, times the dy,
plus the product of the
magnitudes of the y component
or the j component.
So it's going to be plus
Q of xy times minus dx,
times negative dx.
Well, that's going to give us
negative Q of xy,
negative Q of xy times dx.
So, this is kind of interesting statement.
We've seen something not too
different from this before,
when we saw even just the
definition of Green's theorem.
Let me rewrite here just so we remember.
So, the definition when we
learned about Green's theorem,
it told us if we're taking a
line integral over this contour
and there's multiple ways
to write it, but one way
that we often still see it,
and we've explored it already
in our videos is if we were
to say M times dx plus N
times dy, this is equal to--
and I'm just restating
Green's theorem right here--
this is equal to the double
integral over the region
that this contour surrounds of...
And whatever function
you have here times dy,
you take the partial of
that with respect to X,
the partial of N with respect to X,
and from that we subtract
whatever was on the dx side,
so the partial of M with
respect to Y, and then
you could say times df,
dy, or you could say da,
for the infinitesimally
small little chunk of area.
So, I'm going to write DA here.
All right, dx, dy, or it could be dy.
Or we might as well write DA here,
since we're speaking in generalizations,
where DA is an infinitely
small little chunk of area.
So this here, this is just a
restatement of Green's theorem
so we already know this.
This is a restatement of Green's Theorem
and how can we apply it here?
Well, it's the same thing.
You have a little bit
of sine differences but you
can apply Green's theorem here.
This is going to be equal
to the double integral
over the region that
this contour surrounds.
And then, what we want to do is,
we want to look at whatever
is the function that
is being multiplied by the dy.
In this case, this is the function
that is being multiplied times the dy.
And we want to take the partial
of that in respect to X.
So, we're going to take the
partial of P with respect to X.
So, the partial of P with respect to X.
And then from that we
are going to subtract.
We're going to subtract
the other function,
whatever's being multiplied by dx,
we're going to take the partial
of that with respect to Y.
So here, we're going to take the partial
of this whole thing with respect to Y,
but we have a negative out here
so it's going to be minus partial of Q
with respect to Y and then we have DA,
and obviously, these two negatives,
subtracting the negative
just gives you a positive.
So this is going to be
equal to the double integral
over the region.
And maybe you already
see where this is going,
maybe getting a little bit excited.
The partial of P with respect to X plus
the partial of Q with respect to Y, dA.
Now, okay, I took the partial of...
"Well, what is this telling me, Sal?"
Well, look at this thing right over here.
P was originally the
function that was telling us
the magnitude in the X direction.
Q was telling us the
magnitude of the Y direction.
We're taking the partial
of this with respect to X,
we're taking the partial
of this with respect
to Y and we're summing them.
This is exactly the divergence of F.
And if that doesn't make any sense,
go watch the video on divergence.
This right over here
is the divergence of F.
This is the divergence
by definition, really,
this is the divergence
of our vector field F.
And so, we have a very interesting thing.
This thing that we saw was
the original expression
that we started studying
which is essentially saying,
"What's the speed at which the particles
"are exiting this surface?"
We now get it in terms of
this little expression.
And we'll interpret in an intuitive way
and a little bit of this in a little bit.
So this is equal to the
divergent of F times dA
over the whole region
so the double integral.
So, we're summing up the
divergence of F times
the infinite, really small
little chunk over there
and we're summing them
up over the whole region.
Now, why does that make intuitive sense?
And for you to realize why
it makes intuitive sense,
you just have to remind
yourself what the divergence is.
Divergence is a measure of
whether things are expanding
or diverging or kind of contracting.
If you have a point over
here where around that,
the particles are kind of
moving away from each other,
you would have a positive divergence here.
If you have a point,
sometimes called a sync,
where all of the particles
are kind of condensing
or converging you would have
a negative divergence here.
And now, so this should
make a lot of sense.
You take any little
infinitely small area in this,
you take any little infinitely small area,
and then multiply that
times the divergence there.
So, the more divergence, you're going
to get a larger number and then you sum
it up across the entire region.
That makes a lot of sense.
The more diverging that's
going on through your region,
obviously, the more stuff that's going
to be exiting your boundary over here.
So, it actually makes complete sense,
or hopefully it makes a
little bit of complete sense.
If you were to see how fast are things
exiting the surface, it's
really the two dimensional flux,
how fast are things exiting the surface,
and you take the sum of all of them,
that's going to be the
same thing of summing
all of the divergences over this area
that the contour is surrounding.
So, hopefully that makes a
little bit of sense to you.
And it's actually another way of
kind of thinking about Green's Theorem.
And we also have just
explored what we just said,
this expression that the
divergence summed over
this region over here is the
same thing as the F dot n
over the contour.
That is, essentially, the two dimensional
divergence theorem.